hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven things you can do to
boost your self-confidence
so find that entrepreneurs in general
need a little bit more confidence in
their ideas need a little bit more
swagger need a little bit more feeling
they can do it need a little more
believe in their life and it's hard
because we're doing something that most
people don't do you know you're doing
something that's outside the norm where
everybody else is getting jobs and doing
the same thing we're off doing this
crazy thing of chasing our dream and
chasing our vision and because it's so
different I feel like we need a little
bit more confidence to be able to
execute and really realize our dreams so
today I'm going to share with you
several things that you can do to boost
your self-confidence
the first thing is find your one word
and it's not just timely because I
actually have a book about it but really
because I feel it's one of the most
important things that you can do it's
understanding what you staying for is a
human being because you will likely say
no to opportunities that could support
you but you're really just afraid or you
say yes to opportunities that don't
support you but you don't have the the
framework to make that right decision
when you understand what it is that you
stand for you start to raise your
standards of the people that you're
around of what you will and will not
accept anymore and it just really makes
a big impact on your own self-confidence
when you are saying no to something it's
not out of fear it's out of principle
and being able to understand the
difference a lot of times when people
identify what their one word is it's
happy because they have clarity but also
sad because they realize how much of
things in their life are not congruent
with where they should be for you to
realize the potential that you have you
need to act a certain way that is most
true to you and you'll notice how many
things in your life currently from the
people you're around to the businesses
you're involved in to the things that
you're doing on a day-to-day basis are
not in line with you achieving that best
version of yourself status and when you
realize what your one word is things
start to change
and so that self-awareness to understand
who you are what you stand for and start
making decisions around that makes a
huge difference in your self-confidence
because when you're saying no to
something it's out of conviction not out
of fear of being judged
number two is say yes more one of the
things that I find people are afraid of
and that really limits their
self-confidence is they're afraid to
step out of their box not out of
something that relates to the one word
now that's something that is degrading
or is against what you stand for but
just something new something different
something afraid you know as we're kids
we try a lot of stuff we have curiosity
and somewhere along the line as we get
older we are more fearful we're afraid
of trying something new we're afraid of
making a youtube video we're afraid of
getting on a motorcycle afraid of going
on that trip we'll always come up with
practical reasons why we can't do
something but the real reason is that
you are afraid and so what I try to do
is when I am afraid of something when I
want to say no to something because of
fear I try to force myself to go out and
do it and exercise that muscle
consistently so it gets stronger and
stronger and stronger and I continue to
build and grow myself the biggest
decision of all for me the hardest one
was turning down a really high paying
job out of university to start this
business that was struggling and
suffering and making $300 a month to say
no to that to this company that I didn't
know if it would take off or not making
that tough decision it was one of the
hardest changes in my life it wasn't
super easy was days and days of agony
trying to think it over
making that tough decision help me make
the next tough decision help me make the
next step decision helping makes the
next up position and so when there is
conflict when there is a hard decision
ahead of you don't run away from it say
yes figure out a solution dive into it
it makes you stronger and helps you
tackle the next situation and gives you
more confidence people to do it
consistently
number three is have a mastermind group
and they did here's you have people
around you who are pushing you to be
better who believe in you who can see
the negative self-talk in you who have
your best interest at mind who
understand what your goals are and try
to you know gently or sometimes not so
gently push you in that direction I've
had and run mastermind groups for
entrepreneurs here in Toronto for the
past I don't know ten years or so the
reason why you're not doing the thing
that you're supposed to do to help get
your business where it's supposed to be
is usually a limiting personal belief
and you are probably not recognizing
that and having people around you to
call you on your own BS when you're
giving a practical reasonable answer but
they know that it's just BS that really
helps and it could be a formal structure
where you have people and that's what we
do we meet every month and there's
between six and eight of us depending on
the size of the group but it could just
be a friend of yours or it could be
people in your industry that you want to
connect with on a regular basis you want
people around you to help push you to be
that best version of yourself and give
you the confidence sometimes that you
need to make the tough decisions when
you don't have the confidence yourself
number four along the same lines is
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident that give you
boldness and make you want to do
something big and new and special and
different and want to actually follow
through on it if you look at the people
in your life right now do they give you
confidence does your mom give you
confidence your friends give you
confidence you know do your teachers or
colleagues give you confidence or when
you tell them your idea of the day say
that it's a stupid idea and you
shouldn't do it does your office or
bedroom give you confidence so the
videos you watch give you confidence
right all of that matters and you want
to design your environment with intent
so that wherever you are as much as
possible from you know the clothes you
wear to the music you listen to the
videos you watch the people you hang out
with to the conversations that you have
are built up around helping you do
something great and to the extent that
they're not I would have a serious
thought about whether you still want to
have those people or those things in
your life if you want to boost your
confidence then you need to have things
around you that make you feel confident
consistently
number five is take small steps one of
the biggest things that I found in
trying to tackle big projects I'm
starting here I want to get here it's a
big gap and because it looks so big I
don't have the confidence to do it like
well Who am I to be able to go out and
do that that's such a big task I can't
do it and all the negative self-talk
starts to come in where if you realize
that you could take small steps this is
really big but here to here is not so
big it's scary but not that scary I
think I can kind of do that and then
another step another step and you slowly
work your way up realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before and so
trying to break down whatever that big
thing is that you want to do that seems
so scary and crazy and out of this world
and not possible and not within your
skill set are ever gonna happen for you
find whatever the smallest first step is
and then the smallest next step is and
continue to build those steps and when
you look back you'll have realized that
you made some pretty significant
progress
number six is model success it can be
really scary and really hard when you
don't have a plan when you don't know
where you're going and as entrepreneurs
it's it's especially scary because we're
doing new things we are pioneering we're
inventing a future we're writing the new
scripts or what will happen and when you
don't have clarity when you don't have
certainty that leads to a lack of
confidence if you know exactly how to do
something and you've done it a million
times before you don't have
self-confidence issues because you've
already done it right like breathing or
walking or writing the letter A or
whatever like all of these things you do
constantly and so it's not hard for you
to do it where when the future is
unclear it can be really hard and so one
of the things that I found really helps
is model and success maybe nobody has
done what I want to do in my industry
but it may have been done before or
there's some pieces that I can learn
from history of other entrepreneurs or
other innovators or other actors or
other musicians or other athletes
they've done something that I can take
and apply it to my case and looking at
that not only gives me the strategy of
what like it helps you give me the plan
of what I can do but also inspires
confidence in me because I look at
somebody here who's done something
amazing who started with less than what
I already have right now and if they can
do it it inspires me to think that I can
do it too
or at least I can get pretty close and
I've always found that having those
stories around me helped boost my
confidence which is part of why I
started this channel you know selfishly
for me the top ten rules the ant's press
so for me to be able to watch
consistently daily to give me confidence
where I look at these people and see
that you know they were able to do great
things with so little it makes me feel
like I can do it myself
and I need it daily I need that shot
daily at least it's for me maybe you
guys can watch something that last you
for months for me I needed daily I need
that constant injection and so by
looking at what they've done I get that
and I feel more confident in my ability
to go and execute on my vision
and the number seven thing you can do to
boost your self-confidence is try to
live with no regrets
this is the single most important thing
that helped me in my biggest decision in
my life was deciding between having that
job that dream job I thought I always
wanted and running this business that
was sucking was I don't want to live
with regret that's what turned the
tables it wasn't making a list of pros
and cons and strengths and weaknesses
and trying to think about it logically
it was really if I didn't do this if I
didn't try to make this company work I
would regret it we're taking that job I
figured you know what I can always get
another job I mean it'd be that job man
to be the dream job but I could probably
work my way up there and get that job
but I wouldn't have this chance again
and I would regret not taking it that
fear of regret that worried about regret
that looking at your life when you're
hundred years old and back to this
moment will you think that you will
regret not taking action that helps me
bust through the fear I'm still afraid
to take the action I'm still afraid to
say yes I'm still afraid to do it but
the thought of the regret haunting me
for the rest of my life helps give me
the courage to feel the fear and do it
anyway and it gives me the confidence to
succeed and to at least try and and
knowing that the trying itself is a
victory even if I don't get the result
even my business doesn't take off like
yes it worked out for me I got acquired
a couple years later you know it was a
great scenario for me but even if it
didn't work out just knowing the answer
helps just talking to that girl and
getting an answer helps just making that
sales call and getting an answer helps
so it's not necessarily just you know
the victory the win but certainty
because the more that you live your life
with limited regrets first of all you'll
live a much happier life but second of
all you'll probably do something amazing
and special and not every bet is gonna
work out but you don't go off and hit
those amazing goals by playing safe and
by living below
you're capable of doing so that's my
take on the several things that you can
do to boost your self-confidence I'd
love to know what you guys think which
one did you resonate the most with what
did this video mean to you leaving the
comments below
did I miss some whether 8 9 10 that you
guys want to add in pop it down there
I'm gonna join in the discussion and
finally I want to give a quick shout at
the Deborah Deborah thank you so much
for buying a copy of my book really
means a lot to me those of you guys who
want to support me and want a chance at
a future shadow in a video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipts so we can keep track thank
you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon